here's a stunning story that a lot of
people in the u.s. didn't know about NPR
did cover this but by and large it did
not really get a ton of attention a war
criminal committed suicide on camera at
The Hague Bosnian war criminal war
criminal
Slobodan Raleigh AK I believe is the
name the way his last name is pronounced
he had been sentenced previously to 20
years in prison for ordering a
sixteenth-century bridge to be destroyed
back in 1993 during the separation of
Yugoslavia and he appealed to the United
Nations and the United Nations actually
did overturn some of his convictions
although they didn't reduce his 20-year
prison sentence at all and of course as
a very general overview the Bosnian war
was a major theater of violence in the
90s about a hundred thousand people died
millions of people were displaced it was
mostly Bosnian Muslims fighting against
Bosnian Serbs but there were also
Bosnian Croats who were fighting against
Bosnian Muslims it was a really horrible
situation now I'm gonna show you video
of this man committing suicide but it's
not violent at all it's not graphic in
any way because what Slobodan prolly AK
did is drink poison at the hague and if
anything is stunning about the video
it's actually kind of how calm everybody
remains and i realize it's not great for
people listening since it's very visual
you're gonna hear some audio and then
you will hear Slobodan probably AK say
before drinking the poison that he is
not a war criminal and that he rejects
the verdict and then he takes a shot of
some liquid which we later found out was
potassium cyanide take a look at this
take a listen yep pretty hook you a
receipt it stop please
please sit down
yeah I have taken poison not Auckland
akela Calabrian presence madam okay um
we suspend the we suspend please the
curtains bazaar right he did indeed
commit suicide
he drank potassium cyanide the hearing
was suspended he was transported to a
hospital nearby and he died and now the
courtroom itself is a crime scene and an
investigation is going to be taking
place that over over over what took
place in the courtroom incredible story
and I I don't know why it didn't get
more attention like I said NPR did a
bunch of reporting on it so did the BBC
mostly the coverage was international
and I don't know I mean maybe he's
because we were dealing with a whole
bunch of Trump tweets combined with an
aboard of tax bill or whatever but this
is just absolutely stunning yeah and
it's so I mean it's not graphic in the
sense that it's not like it's bloody or
violent yeah it's a gory yeah but you
you think this would be something that
the media would cover right now it was
sort of weird and I talked to a lot of
people even people who listen to NPR
every day and they didn't even hear
about this and it's always interesting
to think about what doesn't doesn't make
news and we could think about why it
didn't make news in the United States
and related by the way to our death
penalty discussion I have said for a
long time I believe life in prison is
worse than death and to some degree
Slobodan Peric must have felt that 20
years in prison was worse than death
yeah for him anyway
I mean I was doing the math and I think
he could have gotten out of prison when
he was in his mid to late 80s now okay
who knows if he would have lived that
long yeah but maybe he did this to maybe
be like a martyr or because he just
couldn't deal with the shame that was
involved I don't know if it was as much
because of the calculation that 20 years
in prison was worse than death but there
did seem to be a political sort of
protest element to it which might have
influenced what he did I'm out of time
we had a great voicemail to play but
I'll play it for you tomorrow
got a fantastic bonus show sign up david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show and remember
that twenty eighteen david pakman show
calendars are now available you can get
them for free with a new yearly
membership find out more at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18